Importance of recovery within your training program.
And this is by the way, this is from a sore necks.
You the guys that make weight racks. Yeah. Well, you know, for Rick,
for recovery to be important, you have to have done the hard work to need it.
So I think a lot of people focus on recovery all the time. Um,
when they seriously, uh, I can't do that today,
I'm on recovery.
I gotta get a cryotherapy or ice bath or get a massage or acupuncture, you know,
like bitch, go train hard, you know,
like these callouses, I cut off, you know, like weekly.
It's from hard work, you know, and,
and I think recovery is as important as training,
but first the training has to be there and it has to be hard enough for it to
warrant needing recovery. Yeah. Now I would say when, when, um,
when I was training fighters, I don't do it a lot anymore,
but when I was training UFC fighters,
it was so obvious when they were overtrained. Like they'd go from the, you know,
they be given me a hard time on the mat or whatever.
And all of a sudden I'm just annihilated and I go, yeah, hey, day off mango,
eat two steaks tomorrow and just relax and easy. But you know some guys,
oh I needed a couple of days off. You know,
I think it has more to do with lifestyle than recovery. You know,
like when people are like, man, I'm just not being able to put that,
get the output, the volume that I need to do for work.
Let's talk about your life. You know, like we out chasing pussy last night.
Oh you were? You were, you were at a strip club. Is that glitter suck. Get Out.
Get, what have you eaten this week? Tell me, show me your diet.
Did you even have a log? No, you don't have a log. Get Out. You know,
how much did you sleep last night? Oh, you don't know cause what you drank,
get out. You know, like when was the last time you had a drink? Oh, last night.
Get Out, you know, stop talking to me about recovery.
If you don't have a lifestyle that's conducive to training, you know,
like you wanna talk about healthy lifestyle, get it out of sleep. Well,
yeah, I know. Yeah. Hey, Jocko doesn't sleep a lot. That's all right.
That's all right. Eat real food. Stop putting crap in your body. Stop Drinking,
Yo, you won't drop your testosterone. You won't talking about,
these guys are having like huge problems with stuff.
One stop using steroids to stop drinking. You know, for me,
sex day every day, get eight hours of sleep, work my ass off.
I think that a man for a real athlete, man or woman,
they have to go to bed tired.
I love that feeling where like you are exhausted.
You see that bed and you're like, fuck here kid. I mean to me, can I make it,
you know, can I make it from the shower to bed?
That's what you're supposed to feel like we've talked about that on here.
That's,
that's one of my favorite feelings in the world of I get to the end of the night
and I'm barely hanging on through dinner. I'm,
by the time I get done with Dero Barton. God can't wait to wife starts talking.
You're like, baby Wa wa, Wa, Wa, Wa, Wa, Wa. You hear the words,
but I don't know what you're saying. Yeah. You know?
So I, yeah, that's, that's great input. Sleep,
eat right. It's, you can work, man. Humans can do a lot of this.
The body is so adaptive.
You've got people that can run ultra marathons and he got people that can
deadlift thousands of pounds and we're the same species. Right.
You know,
we have people that can like paint the Mona Lisa and there's people that can go
and murder villages,
same species. You know,
like it is an adaptive thing as long as you train it properly.